a little over 10 weeks ago
mass rioting and looting broke out in
the wake of george floyd's death
hundreds of millions of dollars in
damage was done lives and
1500 businesses approximately were
destroyed
now today i spoke with some of those
business owners right here in
minneapolis
this is where it all happened may 27th
two days after the killing of george
floyd
the autozone which is right here burned
to the ground
then it was target terribly damaged
destroyed
looted uh important for the community a
minnesota company of course
then the third precinct abandoned
now but destroyed burned and they
allowed it to burn
but more than 10 weeks later what's
happening in this community
what about these businesses that want to
rebuild that want to stay invested here
what are the roadblocks what are the
problems
and how can we move forward what lessons
for the rest of the country
we decided to come here and try to bring
you these stories and i hope shed light
on what has to happen next how do you
justify burning down somebody's business
you don't realize how many people are
have been put out of work from
all this we came to town talk diner and
gastropub
where casey white and her husband
charles started an incredible business
four years ago it was a staple of the
community
and it was hit hard when i saw the
police station go up in flames and then
minnehaha liquors which was on the
corner and i watched
the old side of many hotel liquors come
burning to the ground and
my husband was asleep and i went and
woke up and i go you need to wake up now
i go town talk is going to burn down
any minute and we sat there and
watched it just melt to the ground all
our hard work
it started with people with bats
entering people pushing on the front
windows
and then hundreds of people went in and
they looted not for
an hour two hours five hours and then
they came back
the next night and the next night six
fires
it was it's unbelievable john wolf is a
prominent
minneapolis business owner who owned and
ran chicago lake liquors
it was cleaned out and then it was
burned this is the famous door where
everyone was coming
in and out during the nights of the
riots and the looting
they took as much as they could out that
door uh
laura they're coming in from the
basement where their warehouse is
downstairs
yeah they're coming out here they're
taking shopping carts they're taking
two-wheelers
how much merchandise was taken out
close to a million dollars worth of
merchandise you know what but more
importantly than that
it's now taken 40 plus jobs away
from the employees who live in the
neighborhood right who live
shop and work in this neighborhood what
happens to these families
thirty years ago abe damage came here
with his family from
ethiopia for a better life this is
what's left of it
this is what happened ten weeks ago at
the minneapolis riots
we work our labor our sweat in this
building that you see here
abe uh i heard that the city had been in
touch with you
about one issue involving
a fence yeah so the city as you see is
we have as you see is the debris and the
insurances always have a cap to what
they contribute to it
and the city came in and put this fence
as you see in here
and they send us a bill for 3 700 and we
ask them we cannot be able they say they
don't have any resource
so the city that you're paying taxes the
city that you supporting the community
you're
you're building send you a bill and
you're getting punished again on it
enough is enough guys let's rebuild this
community and stand by us
we left our country for a future to see
the american dream
and look at what happened you work hard
you pay your taxes
we have not done anything wrong and the
peaceful protest hijacked
then the government said oh we're going
to back up and build your neighborhood
where where is the safety what is that
rebuilding it's ten weeks
no respond no response
no response and the silence was as
deafening on the night of the riots
and the silence from elected officials
still deafening
larry mckenzie long time high school
basketball coach youth advocate
in north minneapolis so many people love
you larry
i wish you could be in studio with me
but we can't because of covid
uh what's it going to take to truly get
minneapolis
back on its feet these are great people
i got a
chance to meet so many wonderful people
today these are good neighbors these are
good people
but they're mad and they're heartbroken
but they're mad larry
yeah i mean and rightfully so
uh and in terms of of what's going to
take i mean one of the things is i mean
it is uh a time around uh
elections and you know politicians are
making uh
promises and those kind of things but
it's gonna take really the community
holding those who are in those positions
accountable
well i asked a number of the folks i
interviewed some on camera some off
camera
where the politicians now they happen to
be mostly democrats
but this wasn't political this was
common sense they said
no one's here we never hear from them we
call them they
offer some sympathy larry but they say
we got to have a change and then if the
new people come in and they're no good
we'll kick them out too
that was basically the sentiment they
want political change
yeah no i mean i don't i don't think you
can can i i don't think i would disagree
i mean i think obviously you know from
what
uh i've seen uh that right now we have
leadership that it's not in touch uh
with the community
uh that is not necessarily uh
representing
uh the voice of the community and so
larry we're gonna i'm gonna bring you
back tomorrow night because we're gonna
be here tomorrow night
uh so hold that thought until tomorrow
we're going to continue with you
very important message from you stay
with us